let's unpack this whole gender
conversation you use a device or a
character called the gender bread man /
- oh sorry oh sorry sorry the gender
bread okay I found it really helpful to
think about gender in a few different
distinct categories gender identity how
you define your gender and how you see
yourself
gender expression the different ways
that we present or perform gender
through our actions or dress on our
demeanor and biological sex or
anatomical sex the physical
characteristics that make up our body
that in many people's minds equal gender
okay so gender expression is the way you
present yourself to the world so you
could be talking about the way you dress
yeah the way you comb your hair or don't
or use product yes so everything kind of
as it relates to the outside world
yeah yeah I mean that's a perfect way
thing about so even just okay so this is
funny the way that I'm sitting right now
is a very feminine expression of sitting
because like how we sit is gendered
right meanwhile I'm kind of manspreading
yeah your man's ready you're not even
giving me enough room to properly man
spread over here this is the man cross
the masculine way of crossing a leg this
is just uncomfortable for me feels like
it's a lot to me yeah yeah like yoga
okay now let's do the girl okay
so gender is different than sexual
orientation yeah
but a lot of people get them confused
yeah gender is who you go to bed as
sexual orientation is who you go to bed
give half you haven't heard that one
that one's important so let's talk about
penises and vaginas shall you go right
they haven't already talked about
penises and vaginas we need to talk
about penises vaginas that's what
everybody always things like immediately
as soon as you say gender anybody who's
walking by right now he's hearing us say
the word gender the first thing was
talking to their mind is external
genitalia they're thinking about penises
of exam so for the purpose of our
discussion the bottom line is your
external genitalia does not dictate your
gender yeah wait a second
you rewind that the bottom line is your
external genitalia does not dictate your
gender yeah I mean that that I couldn't
have said it better
[Music]
[Music]